MOVE ANOTHER DEPARTURE FROM
TRUMP’S WEST WING IN THE
WAKE OF ROB PORTER’S
RESIGNATION EARLIER THIS
WEEK.
♫ ANTIDEPRESSANTS ARE MORE
POPULAR IN THIS COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO CDC 1 IN 8
REPORTED ANTIDEPRESSANT USE.
YET THE NATION’S SUICIDE
RATE HAS SURGED AND THE
COUNTRY DOESN’T SEEM TO BE
THAT MUCH HAPPIER THAN
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE FAR
FEWER DRUGS IN CIRCULATION.
THAT RAISES THE QUESTION ARE
WE THINKING ABOUT DEPRESSION
IN THE WRONG WAY THE AUTHOR
OF LOST CONNECTIONS, YOU
THINK COVERING THE REAL
CAUSES OF DEPRESSION AND THE
UNEXPECTED SOLUTIONS THE
BOOK THAT UNEXPECTEDLY HAS
BECOME THE CENTER OF A LOT
OF DEBATES AND SOLD QUITE
WELL.
HE JOINS US.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THIS BOOK HAS
BEEN VERY CONTROVERSIAL IN
THE BEST WAY FORCED A
CONVERSATION WHERE THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ONE YEARS
AGO.
SUMMARIZE FOR US WHAT IS THE
CASE YOU ARE MAKING ABOUT
ANTIDEPRESSANT.
>> SINCE MOST OF THE BOOK IS
NOT ABOUT ANTIDEPRESSANTS
WHY WE ARE IN SUCH PAIN IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
I THINK THAT EVERYONE
WATCHING THE SHOW KNOWS THAT
THEY HAVE NATURAL PHYSICAL
NEEDS, RIGHT?
YOU NEED WATER, YOU NEED
FOOD.
YOU NEED SHELTER.
IF I TOOK THEM AWAY FROM
YOU, YOU WOULD BE IN REAL
TROUBLE REAL FAST.
EQUALLY STRONG EVIDENCE
HUMAN BEINGS HAVE NATURAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL NEEDS.
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE.
HAVE YOU GOT TO FEEL YOU
BELONG.
HAVE YOU GOT TO FEEL YOUR
LIFE HAS MEANING AND
PURPOSE.
HAVE YOU GOT TO FEEL THAT
PEOPLE SEE YOU AND VALUE
YOU.
HAVE YOU GOT TO FEEL THERE
IS A FUTURE THAT MAKES SENSE
TO YOU.
OUR CULTURE IS GOOD AT LOTS
OF THINGS.
VERY STRONG
EVIDENCE WE HAVE
BEEN GETTING LESS AND LESS
AT MEETING PEOPLE’S DEEP
PSYCHOLOGICAL NEEDS.
THAT HE IS ONE OF THE KEY
DRIVERS OF THIS DEPRESSION
AND ANXIETY CRISIS.
WHEN I WAS A TEENAGER AND I
WENT TO MY DOCTOR AND REAL
SENSE OF PROFOUND PAIN, MY
DOCTOR TOLD ME TOTALLY
BIOLOGICAL STORY WHY I WAS
DEPRESSED JUST DUE TO
CHEMICAL IMBALANCE IN MY
BRAIN.
I DRUGGED MYSELF FOR 13
YEARS.
I REMAINS DRESSED.
DOING EXPERIENCE.
GUEST.
SO STRIKING TO ME WHEN I
WENT AND TRAVELED ALL OVER
THE WORLD INTO THE LEADING
EXPERTS IN THE WORLD ABOUT
WHAT REALLY CAUSES
DEPRESSION AND APTION
ANXIETY.
WHAT
SOLVES THEM.
RESPONSE THOSE DO EXIST.
FOR THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY MAYBE IT HAS TO DO
WITH THE WAY WE ARE LIVING.
>> IF YOU ARE DEPRESSED AND
ANXIOUS, YOU ARE NOT CRAZY.
YOU ARE NOT A MACHINE WITH
BROKEN PARTS.
YOU ARE A HUMAN BEING WITH
UNMET NEEDS.
GOING TO SOUND A LIT STRANGE
IN THE ABSTRACT.
OBVIOUS EXAMPLE THAT
CONNECTS PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY.
STUDY THAT ASKS THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN HOW MANY CLOSE
FRIENDS DO YOU HAVE THAT YOU
COULD CALL ON ON A CRISIS.
STARTED YEARS AGO.
MOST COMMON ANSWER FIVE.
TODAY THE MOST COMMON ANSWER
IS NONE.
SO WE ARE.
>> Tucker: NONE.
>> NOT THE AVERAGE MOST
COMMON ANSWER.
WE BECOME THE LOWLIEST
SOCIETY EVER BEEN.
WHAT I WANT TO LOOK AT WHAT
WHAT ARE ANTIDEPRESSANTS FOR
THESE NINE DEEP UNDERLYING
CAUSES OF SOLUTION TO THESE
PROBLEMS.
THERE IS A DOCTOR IN EAST
LONDON CALLED SAM, HAD LOADS
OF PATIENTS COMING TO HIM
ACUTELY DEPRESSED AND
ANXIOUS.
HE FELT REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN TOLD IN
HIS TRAINING EVEN THOUGH HE
KNEW THE SCIENCE WAS MUCH
MORE SOPHISTICATED CHEM CAM
IMBALANCED.
HES IS IS NOT OPPOSED TO YOU
THE DRUG BUT NOT SOLVING
PROBLEMS.
ACUTELY LONELY.
A WOMAN CAME LISA CUNNINGHAM
IN HER HOME SEVEN YEARS.
I’M GOING TO PRESCRIBE
SOMETHING ELSE.
I’M GOING TO SPRIB FOR YOU
TO TAKE GROUP.
AREA SCRUB LAND.
WE WILL COME AND SUPPORT
YOU.
I WANT YOU TO MEET WITH A
GROUP OF DEPRESSED AND
ANXIOUS PEOPLE TWICE A WEEK.
WE WILL TURN THIS INTO A
BEAUTIFUL GARDEN.
THEY MET OVER WEEKS AND
MONTHS AND LISA PUT TO TO ME
AS THE GARDEN BEGAN TO BLOOM
WE BEGAN TO BLOOM.
STUDY OF A SIMILAR PROGRAM
MORE THAT THAN TWICE AS
EFFECTIVE THAN CHEMICAL
DEPRESSANTS.
PEOPLE ARE TRYING
ANTI-DEPRESSANTS ARE ABOUT
DEALING WITH THE DEEP AND
SOCIOLOGICAL DECISIONS WHY
WE FEEL ISOLATED IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
>> Tucker: EVERYTHING YOU
SAID SO OBVIOUS TO ME.
PEOPLE, WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
MAYBE YOU CAN COME BACK AND
SAY WHY WE VEST SO MUCH
UNWARRANTED FAITH IN
PSYCHIATRISTS.
WHY ARE WE SO WILLING TO
TAKE BAD ADVICE FROM PEOPLE
WITH M.D.ES.
>> WE HAVE ONLY GIVEN
PSYCHIATRISTS ONE LEVER TO
PULL.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO AS A
SOCIETY PUT IN PLACE A MUCH
MORE EXPANDED MENU OF
OPTIONS.
THINGS THAT ACTUALLY DEAL